we're going to kick it off by tackling
a topic that i am truly
fascinated with and it's dating
because i am convinced that no matter
what
in life you are contending
and wrestling with and finessing and
working through
a relationship i don't care who it's
with you're in a relationship with
something it could be your dog your
grandmother your sister your mother
your brother your best friend your
husband your wife we're best
we're all trying to figure out uh
or multiple relationships and when it
comes to dating
i feel that behavior is really become my
number one
thing that i like to dissect and discuss
so
is anyone here dating this situation
anyone dating in the wall
uh marina hi
marina so i am in a long-distance
relationship
uh my boyfriend lives in england and i
live in florida
it's incredibly difficult not only the
time difference the time
that we've been apart and we have no
idea when we're going to see each other
next
how long have you been dating we have
been together
for about a year and what is your
end game i mean we've talked about a
life together
um it's incredibly you know difficult
especially right now
because we just have no clue what's
going on um also we're kind of in a
challenging profession um we both we met
working on a cruise ship
so we both work on cruise ships um with
our contract lengths
and uh you know sometimes i'm on one
side of the world and he's on the other
side of the world
and so that makes it even more
challenging
okay so maybe when your industry resumes
life resumes for all of us so right now
you are in a purgatory that you cannot
control
here is the good news is usually
in normal times i'm like long distance
great it'll last that much longer
because when you're in each other's
faces 24 7
it's not good um that said
when you want to build a life with
someone i believe down the road
concessions and you know geography and
things will have to get sorted out
but since none of that is within your
control right now
make this the most romantic time write
letters
find new ways of communicating learn
more about each other in inventive sexy
cool fun ways
say we're going to make this time count
in a way it never could have otherwise
and then when things go back to a
different kind of normal
we'll figure out what we can do then and
take each step
as it comes but for now i say go for it
and figure out every single new
unique way that you two can stay
connected
and learn more about each other yeah you
know like
i love that thank you so much so good
phew
literally like find games that you can
play like
join words with friends and become
scrabble buddies online
write love letters to each other you
know send
care packages show each other
say i want you to watch this movie
tonight and then tomorrow we'll discuss
because it's one of my favorite and i
can't wait to see what you think
get clever i love it thank you so much
and then you can say and when i do see
you you better watch out because i'm
going and attacking you
a little dangle of a promise and a
romantic
like finish is so fun um
okay so that was so fun
[Music]
you